tu es le printemps des arméniens
documentaire auquel vous pouvez réagir
sur le hashtag docu débat un
documentaire réalisé par laure marchand
gilles khayat et vous guillaume perrier
merci d'être avec nous à côté de vos
alexis govciyan bienvenus vous êtes
ancien président du conseil de
coordination des organisations
arméniennes de france président de la
mission 2015 conseiller régional udi
d'ile-de-france dax et être là en face
de vous gaïdz minassian bonjour bonjour
vous êtes journaliste au monde auteur de
arménien le temps la délivrance chez
cnrs éditions également 1915 et le rêve
brisé des arméniens chez flammarion et
enfin philippe kaltenbach bonjour vous
êtes sénateur ps président du groupe
d'amitié france arménie
bienvenue à tous à leur guillaume
perrier vous avez co réalisé ce
documentaire avec leurs marchands tous
les deux vous avez également écrit la
turquie est le fantôme arménien comment
sont nés ses projets ça fait une petite
dizaine d'années qu'on travaille sur la
question en fait ils sont nés d'une
manière assez assez simple c'est qu'on
est allés tous les deux s'installer
comme journaliste en turquie en 2005 et
on est arrivé à l'époque dans une espèce
de bouillonnement politique sur cette
question arménienne que nous avons été
amenés à couvrir en tant que journaliste
en tant que correspondant pour pour la
presse française
il faut se souvenir qu'en 2005 c'était
l'époque où le romancier orhan pamuk
étaient traînés devant la justice pour
avoir notamment reconnu ce génocide
arménien il a été accusé d' insulte à
l'identité turque pour ça il a été
poursuivi donc donc par la justice il y
avait une grande ferveur nationaliste
autour de ces questions à l'époque et
depuis ça n'a jamais vraiment cessé donc
on a commencé à travailler un petit peu
sur cette question de l'identité
arménienne et de l'identité turque 1 par
conséquent et de ce projet est née
effectivement un livre qui a été publié
chez actes sud il ya deux ans maintenant
et que nous avons en quelque sorte
adapté avec ce documentaire d'où le
choix de tourner ce film en turquie en
anatolie
précisément est pas bien sûr alors nous
des marchés les journalistique ce n'est
pas une démarche d'historien et on était
extrêmement attachés au fait de ceux de
se projeter dans le temps présent on
n'est pas dans le passé un vraiment
d'enquêté non pas sur 1915 mais sur 2015
et sur les répercussions que peut avoir
un génocide sur un pays qui continue à
le nier un siècle après donc comment
cette mémoire aujourd'hui est piégé par
par la non reconnaissance du génocide
par la turquie
donc comment ce fantôme arménien
continue à monter non seulement les
arméniens mais aussi les turcs s'étaient
c'était ce choix la mort parce qu'on
voit très bien dans le documentaire à
travers cet homme qui décide de partir
découvrir d'où il vient
on comprend que dans cette sueur qui
donc est dans la négation l'amnésie il
reste du pape arméniens les silences les
secrets le déni d origine les
changements n'ont donc c'est à dire
justement la mémoire contre l'amnésie
c'était cet angle là précisément vous
vouliez traité oui mais ce que voulait
vais finalement découvert en cours de
l'enquêté
c'est cet angle là qu'on voulait traiter
dès le départ après évidemment l'
enquête nous a révélé des choses qu'on
ne soupçonnait pas au début c'est à dire
que le sujet d'une ampleur bien plus
importante que ce à quoi on s'attendait
quand on a commencé à travailler sur
cette question et on s'est aperçu
finalement que ce siècle de dénis de
négationnisme et d'effacement de la
présence des arméniens
s'était soldée par un échec retentissant
puisqu'aujourd'hui la présence
arménienne elle est réelle elle est bien
visible
ce n'est pas uniquement des traces ou la
présence de la mort il ya des arts
manière bien vivant sur cette terre il
ya une culture qui est encore vivante et
qui ne demande qu'à s'exprimer
alexis govciyan vous êtes né en turquie
vous êtes arrivé en france à 17 ans vous
n'avez pas pris la réalité devienne
aussi qu'à 14 ans un jour lors d'un
cours d'histoire dans votre collège
d'istanbul vos parents vous avez jamais
parler du génocide
de ce que j'ai lu et c'est parce que ce
jour là vous avez posé une question que
vous avez su comment ça s'est passé
c'est à dire comment vous avez découvert
tout ça en fait c'était dans un collège
de père mais qui tarde east collèges
catholiques arméniens et j'étais élève
dans ce collège et pendant un cours de
littérature arménienne la question de de
l'époque contemporaine a été abordé avec
les poètes les écrivains et les
différents des intellectuels et qui
avait travaillé sur la question de la
liturgie la littérature arménienne et la
plupart et nerfs et en 1800 et quelques
est toujours en mort en 1915 du coup
j'ai posé la question effectivement au
père qui faisait ses courses est l'opéra
gagnant et qui m'a après quelques
péripéties expliqué la mémoire du
génocide donc j'ai reçu cette mémoire
on me l'a pas transmises dans la famille
parce que c'était une mémoire vécue par
des parents des grands parents
mais comme dit gérard chaliand la
mémoire vécu n'est pas forcément celle
que l'on vous transmets est gelée reçu
tout à fait par hasard et parce que
c'est un tabou qui a été levée depuis
lors par des intellectuels et par la
société civile en tous les cas une
partie de la société civile en turquie
mais à l'époque j'avais 17 ans j'aurais
même 14 ans et c'était
bien plus compliqué que cela c'était non
seulement un tabou mais éminemment
dangereux de parler de questions
relatives au génocide même de d'évoquer
simplement le fait qu'ils aient eu des
arméniens en turquie et en un atelier
alors que nous étions une minorité à
istanbul certes confinés dans des
quartiers avec une sorte de
ghettoïsation qui était celle des
arméniens mais aussi des grecs et des
juifs
donc c'est dans ce cadre là que j'ai
appris la réalité du génocide
ce qui m'a conduit à partir vouloir
partir en trek heures l'arrêt votre
réaction est très forte
oui bien sûr parce que je les attends
donc en l'espace de trois ans je la
prépare pas peur se perd ensuite j'ai
questionné mes parents bien évidemment
et sans me répondre mon père m'a amené
au cimetière arménien et j'ai vu le
vieux jardinier qui s'appelait monsieur
haram qui que je connaissais pas ce que
j'étais enfant de coeur que j'ai vu ce
jour là il m'a raconté son histoire à la
manière dont les choses s'étaient
passées du côté de chabine carrey i sar
qui est un un coin assez connu des
arméniens et donc j'ai compris la
réalité des choses bien évidemment je
voulais plus rester en turquie mais en
même temps nous avons passé un accord
avec mes parents c'était de terminer
l'école est de partir après gaïdz
minassian vous vous êtes nés en france
vous vous considérez comme un français
avec deux cultures comment l histoire du
peuple arménien vous vous a été
transmise comme beaucoup de français
issus de la troisième génération
c'est-à-dire de témoignage des grands
parents des parents mais vous n'avez pas
connu ce tabou l'un à non parce que moi
je suis pas venu en turquie
fort heureusement par rapport à ce tabou
aucun problème à être nature king par
rapport au tabac je précise non non je
suis je suis né à versailles et j'ai
grandi en dehors de tout milieu arménien
saint germain en laye dans les yvelines
et
en fait l'arménie c'était mes
grands-parents et donc c'est comme ça
que j'ai je me suis un peu intéressé au
départ et puis après de plus en plus
j'ai lu j'ai dit et maintenant alors
spécialisé c'est un grand mot parce que
les experts sont là pour se tromper mais
disons voilà que ça m'intéresse mais
c'est des relations internationales qui
iront et on va y revenir
philippe kaltenbach vous vous n'êtes pas
arméniens mais vous qu'est ce qui vous a
poussé à défendre cette cause là
aujourd'hui au ces la moi ça fait
maintenant une vingtaine d'années que je
suis élu à clamart dans les
hauts-de-seine
nous avons la chance d'avoir beaucoup de
clamart toi qui sont d'origine
arménienne plus de 10% des cas marc 3 et
donc à étang et du dans cette ville
conseil municipal puis maire j'étais en
contact avec beaucoup de clamartois
d'origine arménienne sont devenus mes
amis et donc pas de fil en aiguille j'ai
apporté aussi leurs combats et leurs
causes
mais pas seulement parce que c'étaient
mes amis aussi parce que j'ai considéré
que leur cause était juste
et donc ça m'a amené à m'engager à la
fois en tant que maire entend conseiller
régional à la région de france et puis
maintenant quatre ans au sénat en tant
que président du groupe d'amitié
france-arménie ici au sénat aujourd'hui
donc gaz mination ce que ce qu'on disait
c'est que vous dites je suis pas
spécialisé m'enfin quand même vous venez
d'écrire un livre très très fouillée et
précis sur l'aspect des relations
internationales dans lequel vous parlez
de l'hyperpuissance de la mémoire
arménienne et vous dites que pour
construire son destin il faut
s'affranchir du poids du lazer on dit
c'est à dire que vous estimez
aujourd'hui et c'est intéressant de
discuter ce que cette mémoire
aujourd'hui est tellement forte qu'elle
qu'elle rend difficile l'idée
d'envisager un destin alors oui oui
cette mémoire est trop forte et l'usagé
qu'en font les français d'origine
arménienne même les des arméniens de
toute la diaspora pour moi
personnellement il est trop fort et il
est
il commençait de plus en plus stériles
ils en font un usage tourné vers le
passé et pas nous un usage où on peut
tirer des leçons parce que il y à aussi
au sein du peuple arménien des questions
à traiter
il ne suffit pas de dire toujours la
turquie responsable la russie
responsable azerbaïdjan responsable ya
aussi des choses à traiter en interne et
c'est ce travail là qui doit être fait
et la mémoire
si c'est une mémoire tourner vers le
repli vers le passé c'est pas
intéressant ça donne l'impression que
l'identité est en train de mourir
mais si c'est une mémoire à partir de
laquelle on peut tirer les enseignements
et un peu faire un peu ce qu'a fait ce
qu'elle fait guillaume ce qu'on fait
guillaume et l'or c'est à dire prendre
un sujet et le sortir de sa mémoire
parce que c'est ça la grande prouesse du
livre de guillaume et et et de l'or
c'est qu'ils ont transformé la mémoire
en sujets d'histoire
voilà c'est ça qui est intéressant et
c'est ça qu'il faudra arriver à faire à
l'exception
je crois qu'on peut pas être comme
disait anouilh
on peut pas être un voyageur sans bagage
la mémoire est éminemment importante et
elle est fondatrice de l'identité de
chaque personne quel que soit son milieu
sa communauté son peuple et le cadre
dans lequel 7 personnes évoluent ensuite
effectivement il ya la mémoire qui est
dans un cadre plutôt passéiste et aussi
celle qui est actuel et qui tend vers le
futur je crois que guys à raison quasi
minassian il faut être dans une logique
de mémoire vivante et transmettre la
flamme et non les cendres ça c'est
quelque chose d'éminemment important et
cette transmission de la flamme et non
décembre ce jaurès c'est pas moi donc
mais c'est tout le travail qui doit être
fait mais il ya une spécificité quand
même à la mémoire arménienne
nous avons vu avec le travail de
guillaume perrier de leurs marchands de
tous ceux qui travaillent depuis des
années les responsables politiques
connaissent bien le sujet cette
spécificité c'est d'un non
reconnaissance par la turquie et une
politique d'état négationniste qui fait
que la mémoire ne s'épanouit pas dans sa
totalité et
les les uns des autres ne vivent pas
leur mémoire comme quelque chose de
naturel qui s'appuie sur le passé qui
vit le présent et qui tombèrent d'avenir
c'est cet aspect n'a qui est aujourd'hui
un peu emblématique un peu différent
qu'il faut j'espère canaliser mais ce
qui est certain c'est que cent ans après
c'est un tact et c'est un tact et
aujourd'hui si certains pensé que les
choses iraient vers une diminution s'est
pas blessé je voudrais qu'on vient d'un
tout petit peu sur l'histoire ce que
vous dites pour s'affranchir du poids du
passé il faut comprendre c'est aussi
respirer évaluer le rapport histoire
mémoire que ça vous dit
on peut pas comprendre le génocide de
1915 enfin on peut on ne peut que le
comprendre qu'en analysant la manière
dont les arméniens issus du royaume
religieux disparus ont été soumis durant
tout le 19e siècle aux affrontements des
politiques un parent est ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer brièvement bas
tout simplement que la mémoire est une
domination tout simplement que ce peuple
a été très longtemps peut-être trop
longtemps même soumis à des puissances à
des autorités de leur des puissances
étrangères et des autorités aussi
nationale et tout ceci a fait que cette
identité arménienne et une identité de
dominer et comment s'affranchir de cette
de ces différentes sources de domination
et de servitude
c'est toute la question toute la
question arménienne elle est là c'est
comment s'affranchit des logiques de
dépendance et de domination c'est par
rapport au génocide par rapport à
l'indépendance par rapport au karabakh
par rapport à à soi même déjà et c'est
tout ce travail là qui mérite d'être mon
avis suivi traité expertisé et là où je
comprends ce que dit alexis govciyan
mais en même temps je pense que c'est
important de faire comprendre aux
opinions publiques que la question
arménienne n'est pas une question tourné
vers le passé parce que quand vous
parlez que de mémoire les gens s'en
foutent et un moment donné il faut dire
ce qui est c'est bon ca sentant qu'est
ce que c'est que cette histoire il faut
arriver à faire comprendre en quoi la
question du génocide arménien du moins
son déni et la question arménienne tout
court sont tournés vers le présent et
l'avenir parce qu'il en va
il en va de la paix dans la région il en
va de la normalisation des relations
turco armés
donc c'est pas de problème tourné vers
le passé donc si vous mettez l'accent
sur la mémoire
vous donnez l'impression à votre
interlocuteur que vous êtes tourné vers
12 115 15 115 1915 et c'est alors c'est
pas ça le plus fou à les regarder devant
et pas derrière
c'est pour ça que il faut à mon avis pas
c'est effectivement de la mémoire à
l'histoire
ça veut pas dire vous écoutez le point
de lancer un présent de d'armani c'est
une question plus de diaspora seulement
les noms parce qu'enfin la diaspora et
pour ceux de cette mémoire parce que
c'est elle qui a vécu directement les
effets du génocide arménien a en même
temps en même temps une partie du peuple
arménien actuelle en arménie et aussi
cette partie il est aussi l'héritier
enfin l'héritière de 7,2 du génocide a
eu beaucoup de deux rescapés beaucoup de
réfugiés qui sont partis dans le caucase
soyez enfin russe puis soviétique
donc c'est quelque chose qui qui
traverse le temps arméniens qui
traversent l'espace arménien c'est à
dire vous avez autant de petits fils de
rescapés en france comme aux etats-unis
comme en argentine canada liban et s'est
même turquie est également aussi en
arménie actuelle donc de chercher à vous
a pas diviser mais mettre un petit peu
comme ça en vis-à-vis turquie pardon
diaspora et l'arménie
c'est ne pas comprendre à ce sujet et on
est envahis revenir là vous voyager
pendant le week-end de pâques en arménie
à erevan pour trois jours des réunions
relatives à 2015 et il faut que vous y
soyez pour voir à quel point le pays est
totalement mais totalement mobilisée
avec président gouvernements
institutions simples citoyens partout en
ville dans les campagnes autour de la
question du centenaire de la de la
mémoire de la justice de la
revendication
et c'est quelque chose global et ce
n'est pas forcément que la diaspora
gaïdz minassian a tout à fait raison
c'est une question de nation arménienne
c'est à dire l'arménie le
le haut karabagh et diaspora puisque
cette question est beaucoup plus globale
et organise l'avenir de la société
arménienne gaz mais je peux me permettre
le lien s'est pas uniquement génocide le
lien fondamental des arméniens du monde
entier arménie diaspora peu importe
c'est la sécurité du peuple arménien
quand vous avez vécu un génocide qui
n'est pas reconnu par l'état héritiers
des bourreaux vous êtes forcément obsédé
par cette question de sécurité
et si le système international j'espère
qu'on y viendra ne garantit pas la
sécurité à quelques quelques peuples que
ce soit forcément ce peuple va être pas
arc boutés il va être très sensible à
cette question de sécurité
or on sait qu'aujourd'hui dans le
caucase le peuple arménien est menacée
d'une forme par une forme d'insécurité
régional est forcément injection du
karabakh on y reviendra peut-être oui le
gêne aussi t'es pas reconnu la turquie
qu impose un blocus l'azerbaïdjan qui
impose un blocus donc tout ceci fait
qu'aujourd'hui effectivement on a
l'impression que la sécurité est au
coeur du dispositif politique arménien
et voodoo
d'où l'intérêt d'où l'intérêt des
autorités arméniennes et du peuple
arménien de mettre en avant la question
du centenaire il n'y aurait pas de déni
il n'y aurait pas de négation il y
aurait un autre paysage aurait d'autres
mentalités sûrement très différent qu'il
y aurait toujours mes différents et vous
dites et pour finir sur l'histoire
cette partie là vous dites aussi gamine
à sion au motif que la république
française devrait pouvoir dire que le
génocide arménien est aussi une affaire
une affaire française pour voir parce
qu'un génocide sa touche pas uniquement
les victimes et les bourreaux cette
touche l'humanité c'est un crime contre
l'humanité moi moi ce qui m'intéresse
dans cette histoire qu'on soit arméniens
ou par magnin peu importe sa touche
l'ensemble de l'humanité
ma réaction serait là même si c'est si
ça avait été un autre peuple qu'ils
avaient été victimes d'un génocide
n'ayez donc ça n'a rien à voir avec turc
et arménien c'est un crime contre
l'humanité dont toute l'humanité est
concerné par ce qui s'est passé en 1915
me permettre c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que cela
ce n'est pas que parce que c'est un
crime contre l'humanité c'est d'abord
parce que la france a une histoire très
ancienne avec les arméniens ii dernier
roi d'arménie était français léon de
lusignan je crois qu'il faut comprendre
aussi ses relations particulières
du temps de louis xiv on était en train
de traiter la question des arméniens de
moummar mais nos fils avec jaurès
anatole-france clemenceau avant le
génocide était dans une logique
d'accompagnement des arméniens et la
france étaient présentes en turquie
pendant le génocide
et elle était en guerre contre l' empire
ottoman et elle fait partie des trois
puissances la france l'angleterre et la
russie qui déclare le 24 mai 1915 que ce
qui se passe en turquie et inc est un
crime contre l'humanité et que la france
va demander des comptes à ceux qui sont
en train de commettre ce crime
c'est-à-dire les jeunes thuir c'est à
dire l'état latine vers etc
c'est beaucoup plus complexe que la ce
de ce fait d'être oui effectivement on a
des valeurs on est la france on porte
des choses on doit accompagner toute
cause dans tous les cas de ceux qui en
ont besoin
mais dans le cas des arméniens du
génocide des arméniens il ya une
particularité
la france a beaucoup plus à faire parce
que l été elle a toujours été là elle
était présente
elle a d'ailleurs ensuite accompagner
les survivants ce qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui à une forte diaspora
guillaume région c'est un petit peu un
des siens des arguments de la turquie
notamment de dire à la france
il faut que la france se mêle de ses
affaires c'est un problème qui ne
concerne que la turquie et l'arménie
or évidemment ça n'est pas le cas il
faut se souvenir de la phrase que jaurès
a prononcé à l'assemblée nationale
l'humanité ne peut pas vivre avec dans
sa cave
le cadavre d'un peuple assassiné il
parle de l'humanité
pas de la turquie ou de l'arménie donc
effectivement la france a toute sa place
dans ce débat et doit jouer son rôle
pour effectivement essayé de guider
l'humanité et par la turquie et
l'arménie vers une forme de
reconnaissance de ce génocide
alors on va parler et puis excusez moi
en faire un problème turco arménien
selon la thèse officielle turque
ça donne l'impression qu'à l'époque il y
avait deux états qui sont fait la guerre
qui sont opposés or c'est pas tout pas
du tout ça ce sont des sujets ottomans
qui ont été tuées avec un seul
gouvernement
et c'est un gouvernement qui s'est
retourné contre eux une partie de sa
propre population
c'est ça la réalité c'est pas un étal
armées de l'arménie nyon 18 pas avant et
vous dites que aussi gaby nation que la
terre arménienne a disparu en huit ans
alors pas que la terre
la terre est ce que je dis c'est que
entre 1915 et 1923 huit ans c'est rien
imaginons ce que c'est pour nous un 8 en
8 ans on est en 15 2000 2007 c ca 2007
en france qu'est ce qui se passe et la
présidentielle donc c'était hier huit
ans en l'espace de huit ans min l'aube
ce peuple est l'objet de trois types
d'extinction une extinction physique un
million cinq cent mille arméniens en 15
allez hop extinction politique en 1920
et plus d'indépendance bolchévique et
kémaliste se sont mis ensemble pour
étouffer l'arménie 1923 la communauté
internationale la turquie dedans mais
aussi la communauté internationale
notamment les puissances européennes
lance l'extinction diplomatique le
traité de lausanne n'y a plus de
question arménienne le mot arménie
n'existe plus et il est effacé du droit
international en huit ans ce peuple
disparaît des radars de l'histoire
huit ans qu'elle est le peuple
aujourd'hui quel est le la nation
aujourd'hui qui pourrait disparaître en
huit ans alors que cette cause à elle a
été lancée impulsée par des puissances
européennes en 10 178 de voir un peu
avant donc forcément il faut se poser la
question mais qu'est ce qui s'est passé
comment on peut éteindre étouffé
annihiler exterminer un peuple et ce qui
ce qu'il ose qu'il cherchait à défendre
des droits et après se dit robert fopa
en france et la turquie quand même ça
fait cent ans
faux la turquie est une puissance et
attendait de quoi on parle on parle
d'une humiliation qui date depuis 100
ans
à partir de quand la communauté
arménienne s'est elle réellement saisie
de la mémoire du génocide et a commencé
à revendiquer la reconnaissance très tôt
très tôt pratiquement après le génocide
il ya eu d'abord la constitution de
diaspora donc il a fallu organiser la
communauté des survivants un peu partout
des organisations jouent un rôle très
important
et ensuite il ya eu la seconde guerre
mondiale et une transmission qui a
commencé à se faire jour et ensuite
véritablement
le départ ces 2 50e anniversaire donc
1965 où dans le monde entier y compris
en arménie à l'époque soviétique il ya
une prise de conscience de la manière
d'organiser la reconnaissance en tout
cas la demande de reconnaissance par la
turquie du génocide et à ce moment là
des choses commencent véritablement on
peut dater cela de 1965 sachant que
entre 1918 et 1923 et 1965 les choses ne
sont pas arrêtées
tout est resté intact mais il fallait
organiser ouvrir des écoles organisé les
églises parce que ce sont des partie
intégrante de l'identité arménienne
lorsque vous avez une langue une
religion et que c'est ça qui fait
l'organisation d'une histoire d'une
civilisation trois fois millénaire cette
civilisation a dû aussi être maintenue
conservé dans un an plus dans une
logique de diasporique où l'arménie
était seulement soviétique donc
nécessairement de loin et on va parler
de ça tout de suite on réécoute un
premier extrait du documentaire c'est
une position politique que j'avais prise
de dire non tant que la turquie n'aura
pas avancé doit passer un pas en avant
il est hors de question que j'aille
mettre les pieds là-bas
dans des questions des questions de
questions c'est des discussions avec des
amis arméniens qui le font régulièrement
le voyage en turquie qui m'ont dit mais
bon il faut y aller faut enlever le
blocage psychologique
une peur primaire de l'assassin de
bourreau de la figure du turc avec
lequel on peut pas parler avec lequel on
ne pourra plus jamais parler quand on
parle de la diaspora arménienne
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on parle d'une ou
de plusieurs diaspora plusieurs
forcément d'accord effectivement cessé
pluriel parce que des arméniens sont
d'abord et avant tout les citoyens des
pays dans lesquels ils vivent en france
nous sommes des français d'origine
arménienne avec tout ce que cela
comporte comme à la fois des droits et
des devoirs et cette façon de vivre la
république est très forte vous pouvez
avoir
parmi les 500 à 600 mille français
d'origine arménienne une véritable
appartenance à la république qui peut ne
pas être du tout la même
au moyen-orient en iran ou aux états
unis ou en amérique du sud
il n'empêche mais l'identité se fait
aussi par le manque de la culture et la
mère-patrie qui constitue à l'horizon
est vers lesquels on regarde tout en
étant dans sa patrie philippe katerine
dès qu'on parle de 450000 à six cent
mille français d'origine arménienne
que signifie être arménien de france ou
en france je n'adhère complètement au
discours d'élections les français
d'origine arménienne sont avant tout
français ils sont citoyens français
parfois depuis presque un siècle donc a
pas d'ambiguïté ils sont français comme
de très nombreux autres français qui
sont venus d'autres pays et qui
maintenant fait souche et son complément
français mais ils ont gardé au fond du
coeur on peut pas leur en vouloir
un attachement avec leur langue leur
culture et puis maintenant larmes inique
est un pays indépendant et dont il ya ce
lien entre à la fois je suis français
mais j'ai également dans mon coeur
un attachement fort à l'arménie dont il
ya toujours les deux côtés de la même
pièce
à l'exception votre engagement politique
c'est une façon c'était une façon
justement de représenter votre
communauté de défendre une histoire est
ce qu'il ya un vote arménien à
aujourd'hui
non non non on peut pas dire qu'il ya un
vote arménien jeu d'abord beaucoup
milité pour la reconnaissance du
génocide d'ailleurs y compris dans cette
maison et y compris avec public sénat
puisqu'il y avait des émissions il ya
encore une quinzaine d'années sur cette
question de la reconnaissance par la
france du génocide à travers une loi qui
a été votée en 2000 2001 et j'ai
beaucoup milité et ensuite naturellement
parce que l'engagement politique est
quelque chose d'important et que
lorsqu'on a un homme on est aussi
responsable
et cette responsabilité doit s'organiser
pour être servir et puis pour
accompagner tout ce qui nous entoure
c'est à dire la communauté française et
j'ai pris je souhaitais prendre ma part
au niveau du conseil régional parce que
c'est la formation professionnelle
l'apprentissage l'accompagnement des
jeunes donc l'emploi c'est quelque chose
que je sais à peu près faire et mais
aussi avec des peines engagement
municipal parce que le fait de
travailler concrètement sur le terrain
quelque chose d'important
c'est le sens de la politique que je
fais je ne fais pas de carrière
politique et je ne m'adresse pas au vote
arménien
s'il y en a qui vote tant mieux mais
vous savez c'est les arméniens c'est
comme tous les français
certains sont à gauche l'autre à droite
les encore d'autres centres
donc c'est justement maintenant que la
france a reconnu le génocide
quel combat il vous reste à mener en
2012 la proposition de loi dite loi
boyer
visant à pénaliser la négation d'un
génocide a été invalidée par le conseil
constitutionnel
d'abord pourquoi et ensuite les combats
bien paris pourquoi elle a été invalidée
alors ça a été le prétexte qui a été
prise c'est la défense de la liberté
d'expression a évidemment il ya un débat
extrêmement agitées sur cette question
puisque est ce que le négationnisme est
une forme de liberté d'expression on
peut en discuter très longtemps en tout
cas sur la shoah avec la loi gayssot la
loi gayssot ça n'est pas le cas donc
pourquoi traiter le génocide des
arméniens qui est lui aussi reconnu par
la loi française de manière différente
sachant qu'on affronte effectivement sur
le sol français
un négationnisme d'état financé par la
turquie et par l'azerbaïdjan qui a donné
lieu à des manifestations qu'on a vu
devant l'assemblée nationale devant le
sénat en 2012 pour essayer de faire
pression justement sur le vote des
parlementaires donc est ce que c'est une
forme de liberté d'expression ou au
contraire une forme de propagande
haineuse de la part d'un état
négationniste
tout le débat est là justement françois
hollande avait déclaré qu'un nouveau
texte était en préparation est ce que
c'est le cas on en est où
ces engagements qu'a pris françois
hollande il l'a rappelé à plusieurs
reprises il a rappelé lors de
manifestations le 24 avril la place du
canada il a rappelé également lors d'un
voyage officiel
il ya quelques mois en arménie j'étais
avec lui donc il a rappelé au président
sarkissian
la france travaille sur un nouveau texte
de loi qui ne sera pas une proposition
de loi mais un projet de loi donc porté
par le gouvernement est validée en amont
par le conseil d'état et c'est vrai
qu'il faut trouver le bon véhicule
législatif et les bons arguments pour ne
pas être censuré de nouveau par le
conseil national
parce qu'ils ont été censurés une
deuxième fois ça serait catastrophique
et même temps là pour la défense de
cette cause donc je sais qu'il travaille
avec des juristes le ministère de la
justice pour utiliser par une directive
européenne de façon à bien sanctionner
la négation de tous les génocides
doublement l'ensemble et génocide
et donc voilà on est sur ce dossier pour
aboutir le plus vite possible et je
pense d'ailleurs que françois hollande
devrait sûrement faire des annonces lors
de son déplacement le 24 avril à erevan
à l'exception vous l'avez montré à
travers les images aussi bien nicolas
sarkozy qu françois hollande avait pris
d'engagement effectivement de refaire un
texte mais que cette fois ci que ce soit
un projet de loi d'origine
gouvernementale et qui s'appuie sur
quelque chose de fort et inattaquable
incontestable c'est tout le travail qui
est fait effectivement actuellement il
ya un problème au niveau de la cour
européenne des droits de l'homme parce
qu'il ya un négationniste turc eux qui
est en procès et on attend aussi la fin
de ce procès pour avoir toutes les
garanties
tout ce qui doit accompagner le
nécessaire vote et la confirmation et la
promulgation de la loi
c'est quelque chose qui est en cours en
tous les cas l'elysée et le gouvernement
suive ça avec beaucoup d'attention
je sais que les honnêtes gens arménienne
et aussi tous les responsables
politiques sont en relation permanente
sur cette question c'est une histoire de
quelques mois c'est la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme à strasbourg
effectivement qui va avoir le dernier
mot sur cette question puisque de leur
jugement va dépendre la possibilité ou
non pour les parlementaires français
pour le gouvernement de déposer un
nouveau texte de loi sur cette question
sinon il n'y a aucune chance qu'il
puisse passer le le conseil
constitutionnel alors j'en viens à votre
documentaire mais guillaume perrier son
titre le printemps des arméniens est
porteur d'espoir dans votre livre vous
consacrez un chapitre aux justes turcs
qui se sont élevé contre le génocide
vous parlez aussi des intellectuels
turcs eux qui avaient pour la
reconnaissance la société civile est
elle en train d'évoluer contre l'état
turc on réécoute un excellent
documentaire on en parle tout de suite
ces gens du village nous disent que
notre famille et arménienne
dupont comme mon père l'a acceptée tulle
accepte également non je n'ai pas eu de
problèmes avec mes amis ou ma camarade
de classe des fois nous parlons de ce
sujet en classe ce soit en cours de
religion et de conscience seul les profs
nous disent qu'il y avait les arméniens
et s'il vient de mes copains de classe
disent que ma famille aussi et un minium
je sois mes amis mes profs qu'on ne dise
rien de méchant
au contraire ils me disent que c'est une
très bonne chose que j'ai accepté mes
origines et que je connaisse mon
histoire je n'ai aucun problème donc tu
ne vas pas au cours de religion bien sûr
que je vais au cours de religion les
bars que je suis arménienne que je suis
forcément chrétien je suis l ai dit et j
commence alors pour comprendre la
position de la turquie on peut citer
l'historien turc taner akçam que vous
citez chacun dans vos livres respectifs
vieux périgueux nomination taner akçam
dit que la turquie a mis en place une
véritable industrie de la négation c'est
à dire que tout le système politique et
ses institutions vous allez m'expliquer
vous seriez sans fonder c'est lui qui
dit qu'il l'a récupéré cette expression
c'est pas moi alors d'accord sont fondés
sur la négation du génocide
alors qui de vous devrez agir là dessus
et nous explique un peu
il ya une industrie ce que veut dire
taner akçam c'est qu'effectivement sur 7
cette idéologie négationniste qui est
central aujourd'hui pour comprendre
l'état turc il ya une forme de
d'industrialisation de de la
communication de cette idéologie qui a
été mise en place par la turquie à
travers tout son appareil d'état toutes
ses institutions sa diplomatie qui c'est
l'un des piliers fondamentaux de la
diplomatie turque aujourd'hui c'est de
nier le génocide arménien voilà un c'est
à dire qu'une bonne partie de personnel
de l'ambassade turque qui est à paris
est affecté à cette tâche à produire de
la littérature littérature négationniste
à répondre
vous y aurez droit aussi sans doute sur
public sénat à des courriers de
l'ambassade disons que ça n'est pas un
génocide que ses mains cola donc c'était
vraiment un des piliers centraux de la
politique turque
encore aujourd'hui c'est que la preuve
puisque on est on est dans la dans le
prolongement de ce génocide avec la
négation est ce que alexis d'options
revenir sur ce négationnisme aujourd hui
ça voudrait dire bah voila depuis
longtemps on vous a menti
absolument je crois que c'est la
question centrale la république turque a
été basée fondées sur le mensonge
mustafa kemal que beaucoup définissent
comme étant un grand homme a fait
réécrire l'histoire de la turquie et
dans cette histoire les dernières années
sombres de l' empire ottoman ont disparu
il n'y avait plus d'arméniens sauf ceux
qui en voulaient aux turcs
il y avait plus de grecs sur sur ce
qu'ils étaient des ennemis des tur et il
y avait une nation turque fier déterminé
conquérante et c'est cette histoire qui
a été racontée aux turcs depuis 1926
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et le fait de dire
et est par ailleurs tous les biens des
arméniens y compris à istanbul n'est
palais présidentiel la place de taksim
c'est l'ancien cimetière arménien alors
que vous avez aujourd'hui une place où
les gens peuvent faire de manifestations
tout cela est dû et d'une présence
extraordinaire et que la turquie ne
n'accepte pas au culte en permanence
parce que le fait de reconnaître cet
aspect des choses ne serait-ce que de
reconnaître qu'il ya eu des arméniens
c'est une façon de reconnaître qu'il ya
eu un génocide
et c'est ça fait pas partie de la
politique d' état négationniste de la
turquie c'est tout le tout l'enjeu
aujourd'hui celui qui va avoir le
courage de dire on vous a menti c'est
sur cette personne à qui sera comme vous
il y prend et willy brandt
ao je suis en train de s'agenouiller et
demandé pardon au peuple juif et c'est
cette personne à qui fera le travail
mais on n'en voit pas les prémices en
tous les cas avec des dirigeants actuels
comme c'est du passé
alors quand il ya une semaine le patron
soit célèbre une messe en mémoire des
victimes du génocide qui prononce le mot
génocide
pour la première fois il parle de la
première tragédie du 20e siècle
il dénonce le négationnisme c'est un
message envoyé à la turquie d'ailleurs
la turquie a répondu le message la
réponse est pas fait attendre
mais est-ce que ce geste du pape peut
avoir des effets c'est un acte politique
très fort sur la libye drut est très
fort quel effet la société turque évolue
doucement et des intellectuels qui c'est
vrai mais le débat même des habitants
qui ont des amis arméniens des étudiants
qui vont à l'étranger donc le débat
avance lentement en turquie mais il faut
que ceux qui portent ce débat en turquie
se sentent soutenus
c'est vrai que plus il ya des tas qui
reconnaissent plus il ya de grandes voix
comme celle du pape qu'ils disent oui il
ya eu génocide plus ça renforce ceux qui
en turquie faut avancer cette idée parce
que l'objectif final bien sûr c'est que
la turquie reconnaisse aussi qui a eu
génocide c'est ça l'objectif est donc il
faut pour cette idée avance le plus vite
possible en turquie qui est des
pressions au niveau international et que
ce message soit relayé et là avec le
coup de projecteur l'occasion du
centenaire
je crois que ça va être un moment fort
aussi pour faire avancer cette idée dans
le monde mais aussi et surtout en
turquie pour que les tueurs prenne bien
conscience qu'avec des arméniens qui au
génocide et que c'est leur intérêt aussi
que de le reconnaître pour pouvoir se
tourner dans l'avenir gaz maison par
rapport à ce qu'a dit le pape
un pape françois pourquoi est il
important que ce génocide soit reconnu
pourquoi les européens les occidentaux
mais les européens en particulier
puisque la turquie fera par est
candidate à l'adhésion à l'union
européenne
pourquoi il est important que ce
génocide soit reconnu et ne soit pas
placée en aval d'un processus mais en
amont trop tard maintenant mais je vais
vous dire pourquoi
selon moi premièrement il n'y aura pas
de démocratisation total de la société
turque et de l'état turc tant qu'il n'y
aura pas de reconnaissance d'une seat
pourquoi parce que si vous n'arrivez pas
à extraire cette violence structurelle
de l'état puisque un génocide c'est un
état qui se tourne contre sa propre
population a priori donc si vous
n'arrivez pas à extraire cette violence
structurelle de l'état vous n'arrivez
pas à faire d'un état un état de droit
est un état démocratique
or c'est le cas depuis 100 ans pour la
turquie premièrement donc la violence
structurelle est toujours là et je vous
ramène aux travaux d'amis de beaux-arts
sonnant sociologue à l'école des hautes
études qui reprend cette idée là
deuxièmement si vous n'arrivez pas aussi
à reconnaître le génocide des arméniens
la société civile turque ne pourra pas
se libéraliser et les citoyens turcs ne
pourront pas vivre pleinement leur
citoyenneté
c'est à dire loin du nationalisme et
c'est pas uniquement valable pour la
turquie c'est valable pour tous les
états nationaliste mais loin du
nationalisme loin du discours officiel
et récemment à saintes schéma le
petit-fils de diamal pas chaque est un
des bourreaux de du génocide des
arméniens il dit ça y est j'ai réussi à
moto nos mises et parce qu'elle est là
la clé plus la société civile turque
prendra conscience qu'il ya eu un
génocide des arméniens
plus elles s'autonomise ras du discours
officiel et forcément elle vivra
pleinement ses droits de citoyen turc et
en même temps elle arrivera enfin cette
société civile turque elle arrivera à
faire comprendre notamment dans ce monde
globalisé où les sociétés comptent plus
qu'avant elle arrivera à faire
comprendre que ben voilà arrêtez de nous
prendre pour des imbéciles
et puis au pire autre chose importante
la société civile turque n'a pas être
responsable et comptable des erreurs
commises par les états c'est pas elle
d'assumer
il faut pas arrêter faut arrêter de
croire que c'était la société civile
turque d'assumer les erreurs d'un état
et même l'état actuel turc n'est pas
responsable c'est le problème le
problème c'est le négationnisme c'est
pas l'état actuel erdogan et compagnie
il faut leur faire comprendre ça alors
moi vous dites un guillaume perrier vous
dites aussi le discours a changé
un petit peu quand même ces derniers
temps aujourd'hui ce sont les islamistes
qui sont au pouvoir est ce que c'est lié
pourquoi oui c'est lié parce qu'il ya
une forme d'alternance effectivement et
on sait que jusqu'à jusqu'à 2005 le
verrou historique il était tenu par
d'abord par les militaires et par la
bureaucratie kémaliste donc c'est vrai
que l'alternance
la tête du pouvoir en turquie a suscité
une ouverture un espoir après la reprise
en main de l'appareil d'état par les
islamistes les conduit aujourd'hui
finalement adopté des positions
j'ai assez classique de l'état turc est
donc aussi sur la question arménienne et
on l'a vu très bien avec la réaction
après des déclarations les déclarations
du pape
elles sont d'un classicisme à toute
épreuve et c'est la réaction que produit
la turquie depuis des dizaines d'années
des carnets tard reconnaît le génocide
qu'après pour pour pour prolonger ce
qu'a dit gates effectivement je crois
que là la démocratisation de la turquie
passe inévitablement par la
reconnaissance de ce génocide de 1915
puisque ce génocide est un acte
fondateur de l'état turc donc
aujourd'hui pour jeunes et un pour
transformer l'état turc quand une
démocratie pour le faire passer d'un
état autorités un état vraiment
démocratique et donc capable d'adhérer à
l'union européenne
il faut passer par cette reconnaissance
de son histoire par le fait qu'il est
assis sur un génocide
au niveau institutionnel à tous les
niveaux on a parlé tout à l'heure du
palais de shanghai à ça a été la
résidence du président de la république
pendant un siècle et ce palais a été une
propriétés spoliées à une famille
d'arméniens pendant le génocide
imaginez le palais de l'elysée spolié à
une famille juive pendant la seconde
guerre mondiale c'est un symbole
absolument incroyable et pendant un
siècle le président de la république est
resté dans ses murs lexique option vous
partager c'est le l'entrée de la turquie
dans l'europe notamment peut être un
levier pour tout à fait c'était
d'ailleurs le sens du changement
momentané des islamistes à un moment
donné mais ce qui est intéressant c'est
l'évolution de la société civile turque
parce que pendant des années ça a été le
fait des intellectuels ceux qui étaient
des militants des droits de l'homme qui
agissaient au niveau de la gauche qui
travaillaient sur ces questions là mais
aujourd'hui avec internet avec des
réseaux sociaux avec une un partage de
l'information au niveau 2 mondial c'est
chaque turc qui a accès à ses
informations donc la transformation à
d'évolution est beaucoup plus rapide
qu'on peut l'imaginer
même si tout le monde ne s'exprime pas
pour l'instant puis quatelbach avant de
conclure on arrive au terme du débat
vous partagez cette idée vous êtes
ce sera la société civile qui fera
avancer les choses et le mieux ce serait
que le gouvernement tout de suite
reconnaît c'est que le dossier soit
réglé
bien sûr mais comme ce n'est pas le cas
il faut s'appuyer sur la société turque
les jeunes les intellectuels et puis
tous les citoyens turcs qui veulent que
leur pays évolue aille vers la
démocratie dont bien sûr et le fait que
dans le monde entier une mobilisation ça
les encourage ça les soutiens et puis je
dois dire aussi peut-être pour conclure
qu'on voit quand même s'entend après que
l'histoire peut bégayer puisqu'en ce
moment même il ya un génocide qui
démarre avec des chrétiens d'orient en
syrie et avec des ch et dont je crois
que là aussi en reconnaissant ce qui
s'est passé il ya cent ans on est vite
peut-être que d'autres génocides se
reproduise
donc il ya aussi une responsabilité
historique dans la région à ce que l'on
fasse vraiment l'inventaire du passé et
qu'on se tourne vers l'avenir c'est
qu'altran sûr pour être sûr qu'il n'y
ait plus à l'avenir de nouveau massage
de nouveaux génocides et ce rejet de
l'autre simplement parce qu'il a une
religion différente ou parce qu'il est
pas exactement sur la même position
c'est pas voilà c'est passé pas
acceptable merci à tous d'être venus sur
ce plateau dans quinze jours laurent
bazin vous parlera des satellites et de
leur impact à sion notre quotidien quant
à moi je vous retrouve dans trois
semaines pour un documentaire sur
l'histoire des mineurs dans la région'
oratrice sur public sénat
ouah